massachusetts calling in the national
guard to deal with the quote
humanitarian crisis after just
50 migrants arrived at martha's vineyard
now california governor gavin newsom
wants gop governors like governor ron
desantis of florida and texas governor
greg abbott to be charged with
kidnapping for relocating migrants to
liberal cities so what charges should
the federal government face then for
secretly transporting illegal immigrants
across the country you know that's been
going on for the past year our next
guest exposed by administration secret
migrant flights to his state former west
chester county
new york executive rob astorino joins us
now rob great to see you this morning
the world that's being thrown around and
i believe
california governor gavin newsom has
used his kidnapping
so
are those to be applied universally
definitely federal kidnapping charges um
definitely human trafficking by the bite
administration we can go on and on and
on
we probably run out of crimes to charge
them with
but i think i just want to go back to
what you guys were talking about before
this is presentism by the progressives
because a year ago when i was talking
about this showed the video of what was
happening they were dead silent all they
did was called me a racist and a hater
and all this other nonsense and it was
happening right into our own
neighborhoods here in westchester county
it also went to stewart international
airport these flights which is a new
york state-controlled port authority
airport so governor hocal was in on it
um and so this is nothing new to us
these migrants are coming into our
schools they're coming into our
hospitals uh they're getting into
housing all these benefits
they're already been getting for a year
so now that they go to martha's vineyard
and by the way great job governor
desantis
the uh progressives can't take it and so
now they're going ballistic which proves
two things one they admit there's a
problem and two
they are inadequate they are inept to
handle this problem so rob in your
estimation explain the difference in
reaction from a year ago to today is it
simply that now the other political
party is doing it
no question so yeah i had a press
conference august 13 the 21 outside
westchester county airport and i had
video which you have used um at night
time these fights coming in but also at
broad daylight we caught some and we
followed the buses of where they were
being transported all over the place
just getting into cars the buses would
stop at a throughway rest stop and there
would be all these waiting cars for them
to get into and off they would go and we
got no answers whatsoever and when i
said this and demanded answers to our
questions i was called a hater a racist
you know all the typical racist stuff
that they say
um and but i pursued i wrote a letter to
president biden february first of this
year still zip nothing no answers
whatsoever
i asked the the governor of new york to
trigger a law here that she has the
ability to demand that any person here
illegally any foreign national that
comes in here
must register with the state actually
it's an alien it's called in the new
york law you must register with new york
state within one day that would stop it
in new york but of course she's not
doing it because new york's a sanctuary
state and city and the same thing with
mayor adams in new york city they've
been coming into new york city through
catholic charities and other
non-government organizations for the
last year but not a pete but now
they have to deal with what everyone
else on the southern border has to deal
with and it is a massive burden that
we're not prepared to do nor should we
really quickly rob less than 30 seconds
how do you think it ends up playing
politically there are many on the left
that are saying this is backfired on ron
desantis they actually see a victory in
this or at least pretend to see a
victory in this fight
not at all you have normal people of all
political stripes saying hey what the
hell is going on here
i can tell you in my kids high school in
their classrooms they've got five or so
each
you know 20 new kids in the classroom
that don't speak any english they're
getting services parents of all stripes
are saying enough is enough rob estorino
thank you so much for reminding us
what's been taking place for the past 12
months
thanks will i'm steve ducey i'm brian
killman and i'm ainsley earhardt and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis